[Musik]
land und brecht
schön geborgen sichert guten morgen
markus wo erreicht ich
originellerweise in der kleinsten
vollgestellten käme nach der welt
ich habe gedacht es ist sommer und wir
hatten das thema schon mal und ich finde
wir sollten heute mal über müdigkeit
sprechen ja ja und es gibt es gibt wenn
man sich mal damit beschäftigt gibt es
viele schlaue dinge und viele weisheiten
und alles führt dann immer zu alten
philosophen in athen und in rom und so
weiter aber eine spur die fand ich
besonders originell und die geht so wird
die arbeit kennt und sich nicht drückt
der ist verrückt weiß was das ist ne
ewige grund wahrheit aus tick trick und
track
lustiges taschenbuch
arbeit kennt und sich nicht drückt er
zurück ich würde gern wissen wie das im
englischen original hieß weil du weißt
ja erika fuchs ja ich weiß nich der
harmonie dafür die deutsche übersetzt
hat ja die war ja zum teil genialer als
die originale tricks auch ähnlich auch
bei terence hill und bud spencer ok ja
da habe ich mich auch immer gewaltig
dass bibel für nase und so wie man gar
nicht wissen dass am italienischen
original der ja
genau
mich hat die heilenden hände gottes
genau damit hat ja damit hier einst
herrscht und zwar klar
[Gelächter]
hast du das geguckt was spencer terence
hier habe ich also ja auch ein bisschen
zeit versetzt also nicht in der zeit
nach der wahl also ist einfach nicht
richtig lustigen sachen also in den
siebzigern genau da habe ich das nicht
geguckt ich hab das tor über den zweiten
bildungsweg
der 80er oder so und ich weiß nicht was
für karneval für mich vorgesehen ist
zweiter bilden weiter im bildungswesen
iqb
die bis dahin gekommen zu bud spencer
weil du kinder negativ völlig anders ich
habe ich angefangen für italo western zu
interessieren jahre großes steckenpferd
von mireille ich mit quentin tarantino
ich weiß ja also ich hab ich habe mir
alle möglichen gitarre bester google
großer großer sergio leone werden eine
andere nummer als der rest ein schöner
satz du weißt mir mein lieblingssatz aus
unserem podcast jahr john huston
john ford jemand als er den blick in
eine strahlende zukunft
und wenn bei mir einer aus dem fenster
guckt dann weiß jeder der wird jetzt
erschossen
aber es gibt viele große hat der
volksschule oder also ja wirklich sagen
ja ich weiß ja also ich weiß er hat ja
henry fonda als den bösen besetzt im
schwimmen das lied vom tod so und jetzt
soll ja natürlich so froh das ist gar
keine teure produktion gewesen kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen weil das so
monumental wirkt ja aber der war machen
sie die frohe diesem feld da ein
bisschen ex weltstar der war 64 jahre
alt sieht er ja nicht aus da in dem film
sieht den besucher aus zu kriegen so
jetzt konnten die rolle nicht
vorschreiben und es hätte also auch sein
können dass er die rolle von charles
bronson wählt
und war wahnsinnig froh und das von der
sich für den schurken entschieden hatte
und
hat dann erzählte von heißt danach die
teilnehmer kommen zu den dreharbeiten
und versucht aus zusehen wie die bösen
in sergio leones filme ja das heißt also
braune kontaktlinsen
polens so ein verbrecher staat und zu
erweitern und jeden tag bei den
dreharbeiten muss wer eines dieser
details ablegen ja und zwar damit der
aussah wie all die guten amerikanischen
präsidenten so die formulierung von
sergio leone ja die alle möglichen
gruseligen dinge gemacht hatten aber
alle baby blaue augen hatten und er
sagte die chefs die chefs in dem
allen-film companies mit denen ich
bisher zusammengearbeitet habe hat ein
baby blaue augen und alle waren sie
hunde
sind und er sagte ferner sollte genauso
aus eben sein wer gute gesicht des henry
fonda der lincoln gespielt hat usw das
wollte er als verbrecher haben ja
ehrlich und er hatte auch die außerdem
wäre von nac ein heiliger gewesen ja
seine fünfte frau beiseite bei dem
versuch ihn zu ermorden aus dem fenster
gestürzt und er wer über sie hinweg
gestiegen und hätte den film gedreht
keine zeit verhält
großartig
sagt müssiggang erzählte jetzt laut und
welche schon so gemütlich vor uns hin
wird also
müssiggang ist ja eigentlich früher ein
total erstrebenswerter zustand gewesen
wir haben begriff den es eigentlich gar
nicht gab ja weil es den begriff der
arbeit auch nicht gab gab es auch denen
des müßiggangs ich kann ist ja quasi
erst erfunden worden als die klassische
arbeitsgesellschaft im stundenlohn
arbeitsgesellschaft na dann mal los ich
kann die zeit in der man nicht arbeiten
und das war natürlich in der antike und
so weiter nicht der fall weil die die
philosophen ironie nicht gearbeitet
haben und die ganze
aristokratische oberschicht der freien
bürger ja kannte den müßiggang kann sich
gar nicht witzig kann hat ja bei uns
sowas luft die großartige und vermüllt
muss ich kann jetzt rechts feld gehen
und den schmetterlingen hinterher gucken
so dass das hat sogar leicht albernen
charakter und das kann es ja nur haben
ja weil hier wäre die müssiggang
betreibt der der der verkennt den ernst
des lebens ist ein traumtänzer genommen
ein luftikus ich musste mir früher mal
ist sein bruder leichtfuß ein guter sohn
fliegt ein fliegender robert oder so
glaube ich eine ganze reihe von abwerten
inbegriffen
für leute die auch jenseits der arbeit
gerne glücklich sind richtig und früher
war das natürlich so dass man solche
nicht solche abfälligen begriff dafür
hatte also musik gibt es nur seit das
arbeit gibt es wahrscheinlich
christlicher begriff und in der alten
griechischen welt und so war der zustand
diesbezüglich frei zu sagen hast du
nicht arbeiten zu müssen ja in der
oberschicht ja normalzustand ich meine
würde immer überlegt wie sich das dann
verändert hat plötzlich müßiggang ist
aller laster anfang weil das gerade sagt
diese diffamierenden begriffe ich meine
wann hast du angefangen deine haare lang
zu tragen
ich hab das in zwei wellen also das
erste mal habe ich meine haare eine
dauernd lassen 17 mit 17
wenn der 16 17 warum warum richard warum
wolltest du frauen ja also es war es war
ja so die welt war so meine welt in
solingen anfang der 80er jahre war
zielgruppen mäßig gespalten das heißt es
gab
ja und zudem poppern konnte ich schon
rein finanziell nicht dazugehören weil
ich also so unfassbar wenig taschengeld
hatte dass ich darüber gar nicht
nachdenken was schön ist dass du
überhaupt welche stadt ist ich hatte gar
das war aber es war mir so albern das
kannst du dir gar nicht was hast du
bekommen ich weiß dass ich im achten
schuljahr acht mark und im neunten
schuljahr zehn mark gekriegt hab im
monat dann ist noch besser so wie ich
einfach nichts zu kriegen das ist nicht
so ein würdigend finde ich richtig also
im altmark entgegen in dem film den
dialogen war ich kind
du warst unbezahlt oder ich ja genau ich
höre habe ich freiwillig ausbeuten
lassen also ich hatte einfach das dass
die haben sowieso nicht in frage und
ich hatte auch keine chance an die
hübschen mädels ran zu kommen das war
natürlich die die auf die puppe standen
wirklich ja klar also wie über die in
der öko szene also der alternative die
es dazu gab friedensbewegung
achtermann so china so frauen mit
schlechter haut und da wo mein müsli
dampf da bin ich unverkrampft die waren
also das hat es so eine person
also diese ganzen stellen romantik und
räucherstäbchen atmosphäre und so weiter
er das fragen das war nichts für mich
trotzdem habe ich mir die haare lang
wachsen lassen weil ich wegen sagt auf
der anderen seite konnte ich gar nicht
realisieren also die popper ging der
alle zwei wochen zum friseur und ja mit
dem taschenrechner natürlich zum fressen
wenn man wenn man wenn man low budget
ist wenn man kein geld hat naja ich habe
also versucht mich sozusagen dieser
szene mit der ich auch gleichzeitig
inhaltlich immer wieder gefremdelt habe
ein bisschen an zugleich und dann hab
ich mir die haare lang wachsen lassen
cool und unten plo tuch gehabt ok jetzt
mal abgesehen vom pilot kam das ankam
das an bei dem man
also es kann vielleicht bei mädels an
die ich nicht wahrgenommen habe
aber nicht herstellen die gruppen
konflikt im klassischen zielgruppen
konflikt also habe ich mir kurz vor dem
abi jahre wieder abgeschnitten und habe
damals
kontaktlinsen bekommen ich hatte vorher
eine brille und jetzt stellt die
kombination von ihren langen haaren und
der brille das hatte er soll das ist
dieses klassische schema nana mouskouri
und
so möchte man nicht aussehen ich sage ja
auch so jung aus ich hatte ja schon
wirklich so ein engelsgesicht und mit
diesem mit diesem jungen schmalen
engelsgesicht und dann diesen vielen
haaren da drum rum und der brille und so
weiter ich sage einfach nur feminin aus
und dann habe ich dir das ist keine gute
idee und dann habe ich mir dann so mit 8
10 so einen topfschnitt für arme nicht
ganz so pompös aber so in die richtung
gehend gemacht und dann habe ich die
haare dann auch so popa schnitt artig
getragen bis
mitte 30 war und wie sieht denn das mit
den langen haaren so als müßiggänger
markus
weiß du willst jetzt weg von dem thema
ich habe immer wieder anläufe gemacht um
meine haare länger zu tragen aber es sei
nie wirklich gut aus aber woran die
klasse ich meine haare sind noch voll
genug dafür ja ich weiß nicht es ist es
ist das land auf die süd tiroler
bergbauern gene
die haben doch in der gegend haben doch
die männer auch mit 90 noch haare es
kommt drauf an viele ja es ist so meins
ist das modell reinhold messner hast du
ja zum hinterkopf ja und ich kenne auch
so also ich denke meinte sowie die leute
die in den alpen groß werden wir haben
meistens dicke kräftige haare also
natürlich nicht alle man könnte jetzt
auch willy bogner oft sehen wie gut ich
nicht weiß ob sie einhalten groß
geworden ist also nicht alles was für
wintersport steht hat schon ein patent
an der willige naja ok aber ein sehr
guter mensch da fällt mir nur gerade ein
sozusagen rief jemand den ich mit alpen
zusammenbringe aber nicht mitfahren aber
es ist
12 spielen also mein stiefvater seine
zweite mann meine mutter war schweiz hat
er hatte also mit ende 80 tolles haha ja
super
diese genauigkeit aus den bergen gehe
ich mal davon aus zu müsste es doch die
langen haare tragen können
kannst du so auf der liga herum liegen
irgendwo was sie nicht entspannen ja
also mein müsste ich kenne sie nicht so
rumliegen ist nicht so meine ideale form
des müßiggangs
also ich habe eigentlich immer so das
phänomen wir nicht in urlaub fahre und
oft ist es ja so dass man vor schon
ziemlich gestresst dass und dann braucht
man so ein zwei tage bis von umschaltet
man kommt die zweite phase das ist die
phase wo man sich richtig vornimmt
nichts zu tun
das geht dann einige zeit dass auch ein
guter zustand und dann kommt der zustand
der produktiven gedanken also wenn man
so abgeschaltet hat nach ein paar tagen
dann ist ja eigentlich die die das ideal
besteht nicht darin quasi sowie sonja
buddhistischer mönch ja irgendwie nur
noch weiß zu sehen oder gar nichts mehr
oder sich nicht mehr zu spüren oder
stattdessen alles oder so also all diese
vorstellungen sondern dann kommen kommen
so bisschen so
verrückte gedanken es kommt mir so
kindheits gedanken verbinden sich mit
aktuellem ich und dann kommt so die
phase wo man am kreativsten ist weil man
nicht unter druck kreativ ist und ich
finde das ist eigentlich so dieser
idealzustand ja also wo sie aus dem
freischwebenden gedanken aus
albernheiten erinnerungen und so weiter
plötzlich auch so richtig
fruchtbare ideen kommen die uns spaß
macht sich mit zu beschäftigen wo man
nicht muss sondern dass man nur aus
laune macht
was ja total interessant ist also muse
ist ja in wirklichkeit auch ein
produktiver zustand
ja wer ist sogar anspruchsvoller als
arbeiten weil viele arbeit sieht so aus
dass man jeden tag das gleiche macht
und das ist immer die spannende frage
wie gestaltet man musste damit sie
gleichzeitig noch muße bleibt und das
ist richtig anspruchsvoll glaube ich ja
weil ich ja sagen wir so gar nichts mehr
zu machen und so ist da für manche leute
ist das ja ein puzzle also es gibt ja
auch leute die körperlich und psychisch
so hart arbeiten dass sie wirklich das
bedürfnis haben viele tage einfach
komplett abzuschalten das ist doch
völlig nachvollziehbar
aber es gibt ja auch so die die frage
also die man freizeit gestaltet markus
ist eines der anspruchsvollsten themen
die es überhaupt gibt dienstherr ist ein
langes thema oder um einheit grebe zu
zitieren ja der der in seinem schönen
die die fete ist zu ende
wo also alle morgens um fünf in den
seilen hängen ja wird mit einem riesen
kater und was weiß ich was und so weiter
dann singt er ich trinke noch einen
averna auf johannes b kerner
freizeit und was man daraus machen kann
das ist ein modernes thema und ich
glaube und ich glaube da hat er recht
also ich glaube wenn man wenn man leute
danach
kategorisiert oder einteilt nicht was
sie beruflich machen sondern einfach wie
sie freizeit gestalten ich glaube dann
lernt man viel mehr über menschen ja das
ist wahr ich meine die die ist ein mal
wenn du wenn du dir aussuchen früheren
die die anfänge des sogenannten jet sets
die mal an koks zu gunter sachs auf sylt
unter anderem dass diese kombination aus
zu viel geld und so viel tagesfreizeit
ne die hat ja dazu geführt dass dann so
orte wie kampf und plötzlich dann
weltberühmt wurden weil menschen
irgendwie etwas mit ihrer zeit anfangen
ich finde diese zeit natürlich
wahnsinnig fasziniert ja ich hab einfach
deswegen weil die haben tatsächlich also
luxus versucht so produktiv wie möglich
zu gestalten und einen konter ein guter
sachs war ja war ja ein sehr umtriebiger
mensch hat ja nicht niemals die hände in
den schoß gelegt es ist der inbegriff
von freizeitgestaltung
aber das interessante ist mal wenn ich
an diese zeit denkt also jets head 50 60
70 bar du ja was war das schöne an der
zeit alles war nach soll er es gab noch
orte wo man wo man irgendwie das gefühl
hat schöne orte auf der welt die
offensichtlich noch nicht von allen
entdeckt worden an
ja wo man so eine art pionier besiedlung
war wissmann es da nicht mehr
ausgehalten hat weil es so viele andere
kann also für mich hat das so viel von
von von von abenteuer weil noch nicht
alles da war weil noch nicht jede küste
zu gebaut war
und weil das ist natürlich das paradoxe
daran in dem moment wo der wohlstand in
den wohlstandsgesellschaften immer
weiter stieg ging natürlich die
exklusivität verloren doch auf der einen
seite ist es ja toll dass ganz viele
leute sich leisten konnte nach seiner op
zu fahren auf der anderen seite führt
das dazu dass man keine lust mehr etwas
von tropico fragen sollen weiter vier
stunden im stau steht wirklich ist
wirklich ihre einmal da das ist wahnsinn
was ich will dann nur eingefangen ist
ein schöner ort ich habe schon so schön
haut absolut genau aber es gibt halt
keine schönen orte von der mann selber
weiß oder eingeweihte freunde sondern
alle schönen orte der welt sind
hinreichend bekannt ja ich meine wenn du
wenn du mal überlegt also es gibt einen
von von kalinka das ist ein norwegische
abenteurer
mit dem ich mich unterhalten habe und
der sich sehr in meinem gedächtnis
eingebrannt hat weil er als einziger
mensch bis dato einfach barfuß im studio
saß und das war lustig deswegen weil er
kam mit schulen an und als es dann um
den auftritt ging hat er sich die schuhe
ausgezogen weil irgendwie danach war das
ist ein wahnsinnig interessant der
mensch verleger macht tolle bücher und
wir hatten unheimlich schönes buch
geschrieben mal über die stille er so
ein kleines büchlein wenn du dich
wirklich mal versenken willst in die
idee von stille dann musst du dieses
buch von allen gelesen also angesprochen
aber erliegen geschrieben kagel mit
zweig über die stille essen
fantastisches buch es um büchlein
eigentlich nur kann man schnell mal so
im liegestuhl
mallorca zwischen einer liegenden
reservierung unternehmen also weg bringt
ein gast danach unter man ja dann auch
ruhig er ein teil der beschreibt dort
die letzten abenteurer und er hat
sämtliche pole
überquert und so weiter und beschreibt
dort unter anderem seine tour durch am
tag ticar durch den südpol und die die
waren da viele wochen und monate
unterwegs und es finden sich darin so
schöne sätze unter anderem sagte der der
südpol esther stils der ort an dem ich
jemals war und dann fängt er an zu
beschreiben wie diese stille ist und
dass das dieses gleichmäßige was man
erlebt immer dadurch läuft wie das dann
plötzlich irgendwie farben kriegt ja wie
dieser schnee diese vermeintlich
eintönige landschaft plötzlich rosa wird
und bläulich und greulich und so weiter
das wahnsinnig schön das zu lesen und
dann fängt er an darüber nachzudenken
was eigentlich der sinn solcher touren
und auch dieser landschaft ist und der
sagt eben dass er glaubt dass in einer
welt und deswegen komme ich gerade drauf
also sagt ist es ist da klingt ja auch
ohne wehmut mit wenn du das so
beschreibt in den 50ern gab es noch
diese geheimen orte wo noch nie einer
war vorher oder zumindestens kein wo die
einheimischen ja ja ja genau also ich
meine der ist ich sage immer egal wo du
hinkommst auf der welt zwei sind immer
schon da der deutsche student und der
deutsche rennen die sind immer schon da
die waren immer schneller er das ist ja
völlig in ordnung aber du kannst dir
abschminken irgendwo mal allein zu sein
und khaki beschreibt das eben am südpol
und sagt die idee von solar landschaft
wie der antarktis ist genau das der
letzte ort der menschheit wo es einfach
noch still ist und wo wir uns rein
träumen können und so war es ein sehr
romantischer und schöner ansatz aber
halt irgendwie auch auf den punkt aber
wie machst du das machst du das sind
selber wenn du jetzt nicht auf reisen
bist ja und ja da die stille und
witzigsten völlig anderen modus ich habe
es ja gerne stehen ab magst du stille
also ich weiß ich also du wirst es nicht
glauben also wenn ich zu hause arbeitet
er hat dann läuft kein radio läuft keine
musik da ist komplette stille aber die
war schon das ist etwa zehn stunden im
auto ohne radio ja aber du arbeitest
viel vovo holst du dir also wie sieht
müssiggang in einem ganz normalen tages
alter raus ich fand da hast du ja im
regel fallen ja ja am wochenende
nein das ist das ist
also ich nehme da so klein im moment es
ist egal du kannst irgendwo auf einer
bank sitzen und einfach mal drauf aufs
wasser glotzen oder wie hugo egon
balders mal gesagt hat einfach das war
seine idee vom altwerden an der nordsee
auf einer bank zu sitzen und langsam zu
verblöden er hat das dass das kann man
machen auch noch kurz vorm tod einfach
dazusitzen und weil sie nicht enden
zuzugucken das ist immer schön oder
irgendwo am strand sitzen und einfach
dazu seien aber dass viele leute halten
das nicht aus oder dich auf eine
bergwiese zu legen und einfach nur in
den himmel zu starren und dem wolken
spiel zuzusehen das ist wundert look für
stück gruppen wie die hat ihre devise
den besitz von rheine ärmel gabel auf
deinen rücken wer aber dieser dieser
biene maja momente die die sind die sind
schön das ist zutiefst kontemplativ oder
was auch schön ist ist ab und zu mal so
eine kirche einzugehen ja stimmt kirchen
sind ja mache ich gerne jaja fantast auf
das schauen wir gemeinsam ja ja ja ja
ich bin wenn es ist egal wie groß die
stadt ist es ist egal wie laut siehst du
gehst rein in die kirche und es ist
einfach mal ruhe im karton
also dass das merkwürdige an kirchen ist
dass sie also zwischen die schöne kirche
irgend so eine alte dorfkirche oder so
dass sie einen für die minuten wo man
drin ist gläubig machen und ich finde
das ist eine unglaubliche leistung dass
man es geschafft hat solche orte zu
schaffen die ein gläubiger machen es
stimmt also man hat das auch im
buddhistischen tempeln und auch wenn es
gibt moderne architektur die daran
angelegt ist die quasi dieses
kontemplative oder buddhistische hat
wie diese fantastische architektur von
john paulson englischen architekten den
ich sehr schätze der macht er einen
verhalten mit mit mit mit kleinen feinen
strichen quasi aus allem ein tempel ohne
dass du ein kreuz brauchst und ohne dass
du weihrauch brauchst aber sind einfach
orte an denen du dich meditativ fühlst
und
das architektur dazu in der lage ist wie
am beispiel leben von kirchen das finde
ich unglaublich beeindruckend und das
sind ja tatsächlich orte wo man in
sekundenschnelle zu sich selbst kommen
kann bestimmt und selbst in so einem
lauten überfüllten venedig zum beispiel
venedig hat ich weiß jetzt wie das so
klar ist unglaublich viele kirchen und
da gibt es ganz ganz alte schöne kirchen
und das schöne venedig ist diese kirchen
sind in aller regel auch offen das finde
ich so bedauerlich dass viele kirchen
heutzutage einfach verschlossen sind und
steht vor der tür und kommt sich rein ja
oder was wirklich der gipfel das
eintritt nehmen gut dass wir den blick
immer mehr dass die kircheneintritt dem
ich meine muss ich mal überlegen die
kirche ist von der idee her ja das haus
gottes dass wir jeden offen steht da
eine bezahlschranke einzuführen ist der
größtmögliche widerspruch den es
überhaupt gibt ja das ist katholizismus
plus
das abo das ja dann ist man überall ein
transparent dran machen und sagen eher
geht ein kamel durchs nadelöhr als ein
reicher ins himmelreich nein ich
verstehe schon dass die kirche
finanziell doch genau die muss erhalten
die muss frei sein das gebäude und
immobilien sind und so weiter und so
weiter die themen gehen trotzdem ändert
das nichts an diesem grund widerspruch
dass eine kirche wo man eintritt bezahlt
man muss das so geschickt machen wie die
amerikanischen museen
mainz naturhistorische museum in new
york
american museum of natural history und
das ist ja in vielen amerikanischen
museen so die kosten natürlich keinen
eintritt stehen der öffentlichkeit zur
verfügung aber es gibt eine empfohlene
spende die duh entrichten muss du musst
nicht aber du fehlst sehr du verwendest
du tust und so bist du wirklich dass mit
einer empfohlenen kollekte ja immer noch
geschickter als wirklich eintritt das
ist so dieses argument
wie man früher dazu gebracht wo der oma
zu besuchen du musst nicht mitkommen
aber wenn du nicht mitfährt wird oma
sehr sehr traurig sei ja und es gibt
links zwar konformation
[Gelächter]
weil du gerade von oder wir gerade
sprachen richard über über gunther sachs
und diese du hast also ein bisschen
beschrieben so eine unschuldige zeit die
sitzen alle nackt auf sylt rom irgendwie
ja oder im winter halbnackt sich reebok
denselben gebrettert oder in punta del
este punktete erste das ist in uruguay
und yoga ist ja klein ist ein ganz
kleines land und es ist auch nicht weit
nach bonn teil der letzte zu fahren und
ich war also nicht nur ein steinwurf
davon entfernt und da ich vermutlich nie
wieder nach uruguay komma bleibt das zu
den dingen die ich zeitlos versäumt habe
ein lasst uns mal zusammen nach
ungesichert ich bin dabei
entspricht nicht der vorstellung die man
gemeinhin von südamerika hat uruguay
sieht aus wie dänemark das komplett grün
ja was besteht fast nur aus wiesen ja
wir drinnen hand auf und ist ein
niedliches kleines land mit unglaublich
gut gelaunten leuten weil uruguay
tatsächlich wenn südamerikanisches land
fast keiner mut hat ist also quasi wie
ein skandinavisches land in südamerika
und das ist wenn man aus dem harten
brutalen der amerikanischen argentinien
kommt ja das war genau so ein großes
foto immer also ob pro kopf hat ja aber
ganz anders verteilt dann sieht man an
uruguay so schön ja was was
unterscheidet eine mittelschicht
gesellschaft von einer polarisierten
gesellschaft das ist wirklich eine
vorzeige bank diesbezüglich ist
interessant ich war noch nie dort würde
ich also ich finde wir verabreden uns
jetzt mal für einen trip nach rot weil
wir zwei so lange das noch möglich ist
ja aber wenn du gerade
untersagt ist ne ich meine wenn man sich
das mal anschaut wie sich das heute
gedreht hat du du wenn du heute ein
prominenter bist ein wie pia ein
sternchen eine celebrity ja die dem
müßiggang so frönt
das ist ja heute für die nicht mehr wie
kanten früher gunter sachs sondern ibiza
mallorca st tropez und so weiter da geht
es doch immer darum auch sich selber mit
zu vermarkten es geht immer darum die
eigene vermarktung im urlaub nicht zu
denken ja also ich es kann ja für jemand
der jeden tag sieben fotos auf ins tor
gestellt und die seien normal 7 sind
aufgestellt und 700 sind gelöscht weil
sie nicht schön genug sind ist mir wird
doch müßiggang zu stress dass mein also
man beweis der welt dass man an den
schönsten orten der welt ist wo man
keine andere idee hat was man tun könnte
als ich selbst zu fotografieren
die letztlich an paradoxie ihre guten
seiten geschäftsmodell ja aber es ist ja
nicht nur so dass diejenigen die
erfolgreiche den fluren sind das machen
sondern das machen auch die milliarden
nicht erfolgreichen info
genauso ja also ich hab das glaube ich
schon mal erzählt ich habe hin
dreiländereck zwischen brasilien
argentinien und paraguay usa wo diese
berühmten wasserfällen ja da siehst du
da oben wo der größte dieser wasserfälle
siehst du da hunderte tausende von
leuten die damit der bahn hinfahren und
die nicht wie ich morgens im dunkeln
halbdunkel durch den dschungel gewandert
sind in der hoffnung irgendwie oder gar
zu sehen sondern man kommt dann am ende
oben mit dem wasserfall anderen da sind
dann alle mal eben ganz schnell hin
gefahren wie auf der kirmes und die
haben nichts anderes zu tun als sich
selbst zu fotografieren vor einem der
fantastischen naturschauspiele der welt
und du selber hast keine lust mehr dahin
zu gehen ja weil 1000 leute sich selbst
fotografiert das ist eine form von
visueller umweltverschmutzung ihr musst
du nicht du musst du nicht goutiere
ist irre ja ich fotografiere oft leute
die sich fotografieren es geht gibt
unfassbar lustige momente ich vielleicht
sollte man das immer mal hochladen der
ball auf kuba amerikanische touristin
fotografiert die sich versucht haben vor
allem fidel castro porträt selbst zu
fotografieren also selbst zu
porträtieren
das war spektakulär also die die
gesichter die grimassen in dem moment wo
abgedrückt wird das ist phänomenal und
ich glaube darüber sollte man ein buch
machen ein klima das gesicht in dem
moment in dem auch dass das mobile
endgerät ausgelöst wird das ist
gearbeitet das ist sicherlich nicht
müssiggang außerdem aushalten muss ja
dann auf den bildern immer gut auswählen
ja und immer gut auszusehen ist glaube
ich denke die größte form von stress der
wahl überhaupt losgehen also wer nicht
frei davon ist gut aussehen zu müssen in
jedem moment der genießt ja nun wirklich
eine größere freiheit als jemand der in
die jeder lebenslage gut aussehen muss
wenn du jetzt noch beruflich in jeder
lebenslage gut aussehen muss das ist
wahrlich kann ich ich könnte aber was
heißt dass richard als das wenn du jetzt
zum beispiel unterwegs fürs private da
fragst du dich da manchmal ob du dir
selber noch ähnlich siehst oder nicht
oder ist die scheiß egal ob draußen was
wir sind recht in der sich kartons was
von egal das kannst du ja gar nicht
vorstellen ernsthaft jetzt ja die total
egal sei es völlig egal also ja also ich
gehe auch mit fettigen haaren aus dem
haus wenn ich hunger habe mir schon
brötchen holen es ist egal was ich
anhabe also gut man möchte man möchte so
zu sagen du hast eine zumutung für
andere oder sowas sein ja aber aber dass
man sich jetzt und wir ausputzer denkt
'oh ich gehe auf die straße ja und ich
es gibt leute die erkennen mich jetzt
muss ich aber gut aussehen okay ist die
wurst wenn hinter die vorstellung und
sagen jetzt aber unter rückläufigen
alter alle die jahre gekommen ist
dieser langhaarige zausel das ist doch
wieder aus dem fernsehen steckt und so
ist ja egal ja finde ich cool und ich
habe ist mir eigentlich egal ist jetzt
eigentlich oder idee das ist nicht das
gleiche
wir sind hier nicht in meiner sendung
freundchen ja
es ist tatsächlich egal die das ganze
thema optik usw ste 1 finde ich dass das
du hast recht das führt zu einem
wahnsinns stress und ich finde ja immer
gutes aussehen ist kein verdienst weiß
was ich meine es gibt keinen grund
irgendwie sich auf gutes aussehen etwas
einzubilden aus wer nur hass dafür
hunderttausend bezahlt da sieht seinen
70 dann bist du dein eigenes status
objekte ja das kann sein aber weißt du
wie sieg hat einem anderen punkt richard
dieses thema so zu sagen wann wird also
wo erleben menschen heute noch wirklich
müssiggang sagte man anderes beispiel
also jetzt mal weg von bei sich paris
hilton und sehr viel mais und wie sie
alle heißen für die habe ich schon
festgestellt dass so ein urlaub das ist
aber noch teil von selbst vermarktung
und anstrengend muss in jeder sekunde
gut aussehen weil sonst wird es wieder
da keinen urlaub oder sind diese reisen
dann nicht zum teil an diese orte nach
dubai oder so nicht auch von den firmen
deren klauten man anzieht oder deren
pflegeprodukte man benutzt bricht jetzt
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass so
was so was hier läuft das kann doch
also ohne das zu wissen ich habe nie
versucht in diesem geschäftsmodell zu
reduzieren aber ich könnte es mir
wahrscheinlich aber wenn du wenn du
jetzt zum beispiel menschen die jetzt
nicht vielleicht so ein öffentlichkeit
stehen aber die erfolgreich sind in
ihrem beruf und so weiter in welcher
weise sie nicht manager oder so im
golfclub der ist im golfclub das doch
auch stress dass das dient doch heute
nicht mehr dem müßiggang das dient der
kontaktpflege
da gehst du rein weil du wieder kontakte
knüpfen willst du hast immer sozusagen
den hintergedanken dabei die ganze zeit
oder das ist sehr gut möglich also dass
ist wirklich gut möglich glaube auch
dass es viele leute gibt spitzenmanager
vielleicht auch politiker ja die ich
mein wenn du so ein tag ist und so eine
16 stunden tag
haben wir ja das ein oder andere mal
auch aber die haben das jeden tag und
wir müssen noch viel umfänglicher
soziales schach spielen als wir das tun
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
man auf knopfdruck da rauskommt also du
bist ob die außenminister und jetzt
macht sie urlaub in der toskana
ja ich glaube nicht dass du dann sagst
gehe ich mal vier tage nicht am main
telefon oder zehn tage ja ich versuche
jetzt einfach nur ja so einem zustand zu
erreichen oder sowas ja gucken wir
einfach nur die zinnen von san gimignano
an ich glaube es war einfach kommst du
was diese models überhaupt nicht mehr
ausfallen die umstellung der
körpereigene drogen ja also wenn er dass
das ist ja wirklich so die das setzt
unglaublich viel adrenalin dopamin frei
und wenn du viel bestätigung christ und
auch in routine und wenn du jetzt zwei
wochen davon nichts mehr hasst dann
wirst du nicht glücklich dann wirst du
depressiv dann holt sich der körper das
wider was er in den normalmodus nicht
gekriegt hat und ich glaube dann ist es
wirklich schwierig urlaub zu machen also
das ist ganz hohe kunst das zu können
kann sein ja es ist alles sozusagen
immer verwertungs arbeit in eigener
sache daran setzen sind wir natürlich
wieder bei seiner lieblings these von
mir das also menschen in unserer
gesellschaft mehr und mehr zur und
kapitalisten ihrer selbst werden
[Gelächter]
und dass wir so dieses zweckfreie tun
dass meiner nicht da wir ja etwas bringe
ich hab sie können verbinden welcher
zweck freies tun nein wenn man zeit hat
und zeit für sich hat dann macht man
fitness so fitness kann gut und schön
sein und kaufen alles gut aber man macht
das ja zu einem zweck sein jugend seine
gesundheit zu erhalten und zwar immer
ist der zweck im hinterkopf dass man
etwas zwecklos tut ein fernes zu tun
wird glaube ich immer weniger an der
gesellschaft und das obgleich im
historischen maßstab die freizeit immer
mehr geworden als ich das meine ich
freizeitstress ist so hatten wir fangen
an aus freizeit arbeit zu machen weil
wir kapitalisten die wir sind nicht
ungenutzt
exakt ja exakt und das parallele die
kennst du die alte parabel von dem
fischer und dem dem der herausfällt aufs
meer der wie das ist die geschichte für
die ursprünglich von heinrich böll genau
richtig erzählt die anekdote zur senkung
der arbeitsmoral
und die hat die hat er geschrieben so in
der wirtschaftswunderzeit
er beschreibt einen südlichen hafen vom
mittelmeer unterliegt ein fischer in der
sonne und der wird geweckt durch das
ständige krieg in meiner kamera und
hinter ihm steht ein deutscher tourist
der in die ganze zeit fotografiert weil
er ihn so pittoresk findet wie er da im
hafen vor seinem fischerboot nicht so
und dann soll ich das tor ist zu ihm
können ja notwendig seien daher auch
nicht aufhören auch noch ein klick und
noch einen krieg wo früher war die
kamera ist natürlich noch viel lauter er
wird als erste spiegelreflexkamera da
wird ja geweckt systemkamera leise hört
man nicht mehr ohne spiel meiner platten
schnell ich werde das fotografieren ist
so und jetzt ist das so jetzt sagt der
tour ist eine frage stellen und der
fischer ja das ist ja also ist jetzt
wunderschönes wetter sie könnten doch
eigentlich stadt hier in der sonne zu
liegen ja noch mal raus fahren nochmal
fische fangen na ja sagt er führt ja und
dann na ja das können sie ja mehrmals am
tag machen zeit wurde erreicht ja sagt
er wir schauen dann naja dann hätten sie
sehr vielen ja fische gefangen und
würden sie mehr geld verdienen und dann
naja dann wären sie theoretisch in der
lage irgendwann noch jemand zweites
einzustellen ja der für sie fisch effekt
ja und wenn sie das dann machen und
wieder erfolgreich dann haben sie
irgendwann so ein kleines fischerei
imperium ja und dann können sie sich
jetzt so einfach faul auf die haut in
die sonne ja sagt der fischer kann ich
jetzt eben so das schöne an dieser
geschichte gibt viel zu erzählen erstens
die pointe ist natürlich insofern falsch
der fischer kann nicht so oft raus
fahren weil die fische werden nachts
gefangen das find ich will nicht zu
aber der zoologe in mir hat die ersten
zweifel eine geschichte dass es geht
aber egal die logik ist super und jetzt
kenne ich diese geschichte aus dem
deutschunterricht siebte schuljahr und
da sollten wir eine klausur drüber
schreiben und ich weiß dass ich in
dieser klasse über die position des
fischers verteidigt habe und eine
ziemlich schlechte note dafür gekriegt
hat und da hat mich gewundert ihr habt
ja weil die lehrerin meinte das ganze
sei eine satire
das wären würde doch wohl einen
unterschied machen ob der fischer da
liegt so wie er jetzt der liegt arm und
ohne altersvorsorge oder wenn er das
befolgen würde was der touristen erzählt
dann liegt man da mit altersvorsorge mit
viel geld wird das wäre auch nicht das
gleiche
einer von uns beiden entweder meine
deutschlehrerin oder ich hatten die
geschichte nicht verstanden und ich
überlasse dem publikum gerne gemeinwohl
also ich glaube man kann sie so und so
lesen letzten endes es gibt noch andere
ich glaube das bild ist die relativ
android einem alter wo man ja obwohl man
auf jedem einrichtungen lesen kann und
das ist ja bei literatur so läuft es
gibt nicht eine lesart
du kennst die geschichte hier max weber
usw hat das immer protestantische ethik
genannt ja dieses dies ist nur noch
arbeiten schlafen ist für idioten usw es
gibt diese geschichte von napoli und da
glaube ich nur vier stunden pro nacht
geschlafen hat es an da glaube ich alle
diktatoren so weiter erzählt dass sie
aus sorge um ihr eigenes volk alle nur
noch vier stunden schlafen und so weiter
also diese idee ein lebens entstanden
wertvolles leben wenn man sich maximal
anstrengend und
es gibt so einen schönen satz ich glaube
der findet sich in dem ein tolles buch
von volker kitz aus münchen
er hat ein buch gemacht über die 365
tage freiheit
untersagt sie müssen nicht aufhören zu
arbeiten aber sie können es ja
und da findet sich der satz dass
arbeitswut und askese die grundlagen für
eine geistige holzklasse sind der erste
heute zu tun und dass ich glaube das
stimmt tatsächlich vieles ist ja auch
wie du sagst es ist so der
einmal sagen der vieles tut ja auch nur
so als wäre es wahnsinnig anstrengend
der arbeit und wird deswegen auf eine
art und weise auch wahnsinnig stupide
repetitiv immer das gleiche zeug und
keiner fragt was zur hölle tun mir da
eigentlich gerade das größte problem ist
immer das entweder oder man denkt an all
die leute die ganz viel gearbeitet haben
und auch das glück hatten ordentlich
geld zu verdienen
die dann sagen so jetzt bin 55 oder so
jetzt reicht's mir jetzt zieh ich
irgendwo im süden der usa oder nach
mallorca ja kaufen wir da eine porno
rosa ja manchmal ja ein richtig schönes
leben
und diese orte sinnvoll mit
unglücklichen senioren ja weil du hast
die beste zeit eines lebens als du so
richtig schön schön und tüchtigen und
bars und im saft stand ja alles der
arbeit untergeordnet das willst du dann
alles nachholen aber das erste was land
ist krankheiten brechen aus ja und ein
tag hat keine kontur mehr und wenn du 30
jahre lang auf diese kultur ja die sich
tief eingegraben hat dann weisst du oft
nichts mehr mit ihr anzufangen und die
alkoholiker quote ist in rom und das
passiert sehr sehr schnell das heißt
also wenn du einmal in die einrichtung
übertrieben hast es ist unglaublich
schwer in ideal spur zurück zu kommen
sondern es kann dann sehr leicht
passieren dass das ganze ins gegenteil
kippen
woraus man ja schließen kann zugleich
sorgen der sie waren wir haben vom
lieben gott oder von der evolution nicht
so designt ist ja entweder gar nichts zu
tun oder eben umgekehrt alles dem tun
unterzuordnen und das problem bei
unserem tun ist ja du hast dein tagwerk
geschafft aber wenn du ins bett gehe ist
denkt an das tagwerk von morgen
also im grunde genommen gleichen
menschen die so und diese arbeitsgebiete
sind welten erobern die mit jedem neu
erschlossenen kontinent immer nur eine
neue grenze erreicht aber nie einen
zustand der zufriedenheit und das ist
auch was max weber geschrieben hat in
dem er eben gesagt hat dass kapitalismus
unzufriedenheit sich kategorisch
ausschließen ja eine zufriedene
gesellschaft ja das schlimmste was dem
kapitalismus passieren kann
dass das wollen wir alle nicht nur der
ton ist sich an dieses buch haben wir
darüber gesprochen james saß mir glaube
ich heiße anna sie nannten ist aber die
nasa arbeitet
das ist ein super buch war genau das
eigentlich beschreibt und im grunde weil
wir über müssiggang sprechen zum schluss
noch kurs
ich glaube dass das leben der menschheit
war bis vor 2 300 jahren eigentlich
genau das das war doch eigentlich sehr
viel müssiggang mehr wir haben ja immer
so die vorstellung oder oder oder 1000
jahre wann fängt das an als es ist ein
bild des nw dem sesshaft werden oder
wann fängt das wir haben die spannendste
frage ist doch wenn du dich jetzt in
eine historische zeit zurück beamen
solltest ja und du bist ein
durchschnittsbürger muss kein könig oder
so in welche epoche würde man sich
zurück blieben und sagen diese ganze
mühle und diese verwertung und sowas
nicht da aber das leben trotzdem gut das
wird schwierig weil ich natürlich in
früheren zeiten die meisten leute
wahnsinnig abend planen und nicht alt
geworden sind das macht das so schwierig
ja also ich meine es ist nicht unter dem
aspekt der armut nur nicht dass uns
falsch verstehen sondern unter dem
aspekt des müßiggangs und dieser soll im
alten athen freier bürger gewesen zu
sein muss schon toll gewesen kinder und
so diese diese dieses dauernde
arbeiten ora et labora ja diese dieser
diese dieser bern protestantische
pflichterfüllung dann ist er da kann man
doch sagen komm mal philosophie ist ja
ein abfallprodukt der langeweile also
nur nur die müßiggänger rischen
gefährlich gegnerische oberschicht in
athen und in anderen teilen
griechenlands konnte sich noch erlauben
gründlich über das leben nachzudenken
die hauptvoraussetzung war ja erst mal
dass man nicht arbeitete sondern dass
man wirklich die chance dazu hatte
und die produktivsten fahrers der
philosophie sind immer die wo leute den
kopf frei hatten sich überhaupt damit zu
beschäftigen und dann sind die zweite
zeit die ihr gespannt ist so die
aufklärungszeit
natürlich klar der normale bauer ende
des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts oder so dem
ging es nicht gut da brauchen wir gar
nicht lange zurück zu diskutieren schon
gar nicht in den bergregionen wo du
herkommst das war die ärmsten regionen
überhaupt ja ja also bergbauer waren
diejenigen die keine fruchtbaren diesen
im tal abgekriegt hat
da gibt es ein paar ausnahmen aber im
prinzip waren das alles wahnsinnig arme
region und das ist ja auch nicht so ein
leben mit dem man tauschen wollte die
hatten im winter hatten jene müßiggangs
zeit aber dann war es dunkel oder was
kalt usw da sah es so aus wie es in
deutschland ausgeht wenn das gas
abgestellt wird man hat dann gibt es
auch eine form von gemüse ich kann weil
wir ganz viele fabriken haben werden die
nicht mehr produzieren und ich glaube
das wird eine sehr unheilvollen
müßiggangs zeit sein ja mir geht's um
was anderes und ich hatte mich jetzt
sozusagen um diese diese frage was ist
muse und was ist richtig harte arbeit
und zwar diese diese vorstellung von
arbeit die einen quält und die dann
fertig macht weil du gerade südtirol
sagst ich habe
eine eine an der alte untersuchung
gefunden
italienische psychologen haben vor ein
paar jahren mal die lebensgewohnheiten
von von südtiroler bergbauer sich
angeschaut und haben wir nicht völlig
interessante entdeckung gemacht nämlich
die entdeckung dass die alten berg bauen
so erlebe ich das auch wenn ich mit den
immer wieder mal zum gespräch wer die
unterscheiden nicht zwischen arbeit und
bösiger das ist der entscheidende punkt
diese unterscheidung gibt die gar nicht
sozusagen arbeit und freizeit das sind
das sind nicht zwei unterschiedliche
konzepte sondern das leben ist ein
langer ruhiger fluss und es steht an was
gerade ansteht und es völlig egal wann
es ist dass wir dann gemacht und wenn
neujahrsmorgen ist dann wird die kuh
selbstverständlich genauso gemolken wie
an allen anderen 364 tagen des jahres
auf das leben der drei und nicht nein
natürlich nicht gott gott hatte hatte
ich auch beruf ja an diesem platz in der
welt sein tagwerk zu tun ja und ein
tagwerk besteht eben alternierend ja aus
dem sachen wo ranklotzen musst ja und je
nach jahreszeit wenn das weniger ist die
freizeit ist eine erfindung der
gewerkschaften
brüder zur sonne zur freizeit
über freizeit trifft die sache besser
weil freizeit heißt ja freien raum zu
erkämpfen für arbeiter die 16 stunden am
tag gearbeitet haben da kommt der
freizeit begriffe da kommt eben auch die
trennung von arbeit muss her
und man muss ja nicht lange zu
philosophieren das was menschen junge
menschen sich heute vom leben erwarten
ist ja genau das was du über die
bergbauern gesagt hast keine strikte
trennung zwischen freizeit und arbeit ja
sondern beides gerne tun ja und beides
nach eigenem rhythmus ineinander und
auseinander schließen dass das ist wenn
ich mal mein leben wir haben gucken es
ist ziemlich genau das wie ich lebe
genau dass deswegen ist auch sagen diese
idee von richtig
weil sie von richtig harte anstrengungen
im sinne von das macht mich fertig da
will ich gar nicht hin lassen das nervt
mich da habe ich schon auer drei tage
davor das habe ich eigentlich so nicht
und du bist auch glaube ich in einer
ähnlichen lage was wahrscheinlich auch
die tage die irrsinnig anstrengend sind
die die haben wir alle aber ich habe mal
sagen absolut selbst gewählt dass ich
druck habe wie das mal so geben dann
liegt das daran dass ich mich
überschätzt hat umgedacht hat ich krieg
das gelassener hin also der größte teil
meines beruflichen stress ist es selbst
geschaffen und das kann wahrlich nicht
jeder von sich sagen sondern viele
menschen arbeiten in berufen in dem sie
nichts davon selbst haben ob das der
sondern wo sie arbeitsbedingungen
vorfinden für die sie nichts können ja
und wo sie dann wirklich harte in die
müde genommen werden genau aber die sind
nicht unterscheidungen das ist auch
glaube ich dass was was james assmann da
beschreibt gesagt bevor menschen
sesshaft geworden sind also unsere
wirklich die vorfahren in der höhle die
die muss man sich so beschreibt er das
eigentlich genauso vorstellen die sind
los auf die jagd wenn sie hunger hatten
oder beeren sammeln wenn sie hunger
hatten unter sonsten haben den tag
genossen richtig und der adresse kamen
dann in die welt sozusagen in dem moment
wo die beschlossen haben sesshaft zu
werden ja da hast du josefs die
sesshaftigkeit ist der beginn im grunde
genommen der grund vorstellung dessen
was wir uns heute unter arbeit von warum
weil dann hast du plötzlich tiere um die
du dich kümmern muss dann hast du
plötzlich weizen den du aussehen muss
den du ernten musste wohl zwischendurch
gucken muss ok wächst das hat dass
genügend wasser usw also das ist der
moment
in dem sozusagen der stress in die welt
kommt es fand fand ich sehr interessant
und irgendwie auch einleuchtend übrigens
ist das eine ganz große übereinstimmung
zwischen haßmann und marx was mir nicht
weiß wer geld hat sich mit anderen
sachen geschäftsmann ist madonna ja
genug aber max hat gesagt die
bedingungen unter denen menschen leben
hängt von den bedingungen ab unter denen
sie ihre nahrungsmittel produziert sagt
und in der zeit als nahrungsmittel nicht
produziert sondern vorgefunden wurden
das ist immer so ein bisschen so ein
ideal sehnsuchtsort der kommunisten
gewesen das 20 uhr kommunist nicht von
stalin mao und an den verbrechern
sondern sozusagen von den leuten die als
noch gar keinen kommunistischen länder
gab sich sowas überlegt haben ja dass
man also im grunde genommen rauskommt
von den abhängigkeiten die man durch die
arbeitswelt geschaffen hat
und das kann sein dass wir unsere
gesellschaft sind weder sehr
fortgeschritten verglichen mit dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert und da werden
wir sicher auch noch weiter
fortschreiben ich glaube auch und ich
glaube auch dass das eine produktive
phase werden werden also wenn es stimmt
dass
gutenberg den buchdruck erfunden hat
weil er keinen bock hat der bücher
abzuschreiben wenn das so war und wenn
weil sie nicht carl benz das automobil
erfunden hat weil er keinen bock hatte
zu fuß zu gehen dann deutet das darauf
hin dass uns in nächster zeit
wahrscheinlich viele großartige
erfindungen blüten beim müssiggang na ja
also ich glaube wer wert zulässigkeit
fähig es kann auch kein herrscher sein
ich gesagt
also richard in diesem sinne ab in den
nächsten liegestuhl ja urlaub eine
bergwiese und war sehr sehr schön mal
wieder zu hören vor allem da der friseur
geschichten das habe ich so noch nicht
drauf gehabt ja ja das wieder was los
ist vor der öffentlichkeit sorgsam
verborgen
doch wo dich aus markus du auch bist
dann ja ein kater
eine produktion von m 52 und posters
bayern er im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]